Stars, galaxy, in astral seas abound, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man's overwanked.
Liberty is such a wonder thing, behind us all come see come take your place, we're leaving soon for a bulldozer, we then dispose of him.
Too powerful times he goes so far as to be ridiculous, indeed I wonder why he has any followers at all, you would think they'd laugh in his face.
Remember, the masses always need a strong father, mustn't lose sight of that.
I dare say we can counter our friends.
As for the professor's liberals, we can create sufficient obstacles to nullify their actions.
Besides, they're children when it comes to politics.
No, they'll never be elected heads or in the...
To our general, we will soon be total masters of the universe.
You'll see.
The confederation, an organization you insisted we join,
has been a constant impediment to the legitimate aspirations of our people,
forcing their will upon all our neighboring planets.
Nicely said, chief.
It is their fault that all our attempts at creating successful relations have failed.
We'd come to a new planet, for example, the planet Leto, and there they are.
And the green planet, a paradise if there ever was one.
And what do we find?
And my nice new ships, I hate to think about them.
The Nautilus and the Moray, they were blown to smithereen.
Clarus, where the inhabitants were on our side, ready to act when we gave the word, them again.
Through all these insults, we've done nothing despite our clear superiority.
We have shown restraint, and how are we repaid?
We have been castigated at every turn.
We have cast our lot with the planet Diane under ideal conditions.
And we all know what happened.
And now their latest interference is the worst yet.
There we had the finest allies one might hope for.
And what was the result? We were ridiculed.
We were ridiculed.
Again, we were thwarted. And I ask you, by whom, huh?
Yes, and who was it?
Yeah, exactly who was it again?
It was them!
The situation is no longer what it was.
Now, with our recent successes, we're assured of victory.
The confederation will surely retaliate.
Yes, certainly.
Only I would like to remind you that we had the power of veto there.
Veto?
And anyway, Omega possesses no heavy cruisers equal to ours as yet.
Omega is no longer an obstacle.
And the Earth?
Oh, yes, let's speak of the Earth.
It's the Earth that dominates the confederation and dictates its policies.
And this role belongs to our people now.
Wherein lies the Earth's superiority?
Mainly, it's extraordinary culture.
It's passed its high degree of civilization.
Indeed, let us look into this civilization.
Or rather, what it has turned into, Consul.
I've just come back from Omega.
I urge you all to concentrate on what you are going to see
and learn the real nature of this civilization,
which would claim to dominate the universe.
Kill them because they are dangerous.
Sometimes we tend to be rather careless.
If we continue to dispose of unwanted objects in this fashion,
a time will come very soon when pollution will be our number one problem.
Let's not dwell on such morose matters.
We are pleased to announce that the 30 billionth inhabitant of the earth was just born in Bombay.
As you can see, we do have a few problems in housing the rest and in feeding them as well.
But with a little goodwill, we will manage these problems.
The streets of our cities provide a fascinating spectacle
A delight to anyone with an ounce of curiosity
Fortunately, our society has a few million people who are overfed
To compensate for the hundreds of millions who are underfed
Despite some minor difficulties due to a lack of certain energy sources
Which are surely temporary in nature
Vehicle production continues to break all records
Because our fellow citizens retain a touching affection for the family car
Their traditional symbol of individual freedom
I have just been informed that a new record has been set
A traffic jam lasting 176 hours?
Well done, those of you who survived.
But we also have vehicles that never encounter difficulties in traffic at all.
Did you know that at present our stock of explosives amounts to 40 tons per person
and we are looking forward to achieving 50 tons in the near future?
Again, congratulations to the survivors.
All this I find rather disquieting.
They're all crazy on Earth.
The whole planet is man.
It's a sick planet that is not the same thing.
My suggestion, we take all the Earthlings away to another planet and we use the Earth as dumping ground for all our unwanted junk.
When it's filled up, we just set fire to the entire planet. It should make for quite a show.
You have seen their puny armaments. You have seen how backward they are.
Barbarians, we will now impose order on their civilization. Discipline!
These documents are a thousand years old. Earth is our ally and very helpful to us.
No, Earthlings are arrogant.
Exactly. It's about time we show them their place.
Be ready for retaliation. Earthlings will fight back and they have allies.
Earth will bow to us. We will impose our will. We are stronger and we will prove it.
Yes, we will prove it.
The day when we are undisputed masters of the Earth, have absolute control over the Omega Confederation,
then as a result over all galaxies, then we will be rulers of the universe.
We all agree with you, General. However, the Omega Confederation possesses means of hindering us.
I am at present engaged in top-secret negotiations with a new world which represents for us a power that knows no limit,
and nothing in the universe can stop us now.
Here is my plan.
Cold war with Omega, cutting off all communications with them as we prepare our base.
Our base?
Yeah.
Constellation of Triton is a tiny little system that is made up of a giant red sun.
A white dwarf star, a small planet satellite provided with a red moon, that's all.
This system is ideally situated halfway between our constellation and the outer edge of the galaxy,
the outer region where the solar system is located.
May I say, may I take the liberty of pointing out the conditions for supporting life are hostile.
The high quantity of carbon dioxide in the atmosphere accelerates the pulse rate.
Life expectancy is extremely short.
You are well informed, Professor.
We will send any troublesome individuals who refuse to support our policies.
I can assure you there will be no shortage of candidates.
That is my plan. As soon as our base is ready, I'll send our best ships, our best equipment, and our best soldiers there.
Our very best.
Earth will be on its knees.
General, sir, Kohler's sun is located within two billion miles of the Triton system, and it is unstable, sir.
And it might explode at any moment in a supernova explosion. It would have catastrophic results on anyone.
Your inevitable scruples, professor, even when it concerns enemies of the state.
I consider it a tragedy that not one among us here has learned the lesson of history.
I understand the highest secrecy. No one is to know what we are doing.
Alert all our craft. They are not to allow any alien intruders into our galactic region, certainly not the Umayvans.
All right, Chief. Well said. Only I was just wondering, what do we do if they decide to take reprisal against our 600?
The 600 building the base? I couldn't care less. All I want is for the base to be operational.
Oh, well, you want to take a look?
Mustard technicians.
We're very good.
Soon Omega is going to be destroyed.
Yes, destroyed.
The situation is serious.
Our relations with General Grouchly are hindered by his constant recourse to force.
Right now, what's he brewing?
We must find out.
We have to be ready for any eventuality.
Now, two of our reconnaissance ships have been reported missing.
If we send a large force, we could start a war.
Hero, your team is good at getting out of awkward situations.
The computer chose you for this mission.
With sadness that I have to tell you what the mission is.
I don't know if you are going to return.
I know you will both do your best.
Naturally, I mean all three, of course.
The outer limits of Cassiopeia.
Three of our cruisers are standing ready to assist you.
Beyond that, you are on your own.
No one can go to your assistance.
You are to discover what is going on out there.
Good luck.
I'm in, Piero.
Approaching Cassiopeia, nothing to report.
Wonder what sort of welcome we're going to get.
Hope this time there will be some mild amusement.
And just when does all the fun begin?
all of our controls are jammed call omega can do anything with us sir can't you see there are
two of us here gero can you hear me gero answer me gero we're not doing too well on a great deal
in this prison don't worry we'll get out of really should eat you know no thanks metro if this place
does not appeal to you well why do you stay we can get out quite easily because even if we do succeed
in getting away we won't have accomplished our shh it's you is it doing here when i was informed
that you were here i rushed right over how sad it is to see you in such a place truly i am saddened
if only you would tell me why you came without an invitation naturally i'd do all that i could
a special reason console a routine mission like any other tea yes of course your companion said
precisely the same thing to justify your presence within our territory it is very difficult to
believe you're telling the truth our intentions are peaceful and i trust that your intentions
are equally peaceful.
Need I call to your attention
that we are the most
peace-loving galaxy of all
and that we have no lessons
to learn from anyone,
certainly not you.
You understand?
To make more of an effort to speak
if you expect me to do
anything to assist you.
It was a routine.
It was a good job.
You realize we hold
the lady president's son
as our hostage.
Double the guard on him.
He can't.
Sorry, Chief.
No one's ever
from one of our
high-security prisons.
Not one.
All right, Metro.
How will you get us out of here?
I have taken the liberty of studying all the controls and surveillance circuits and the alarms.
All that is easy as a child's game.
And I can cut the bars, of course.
Now, the only main problem is the beam network out there.
If I could have a closer look.
I just figured something out, Pyrrho.
Oh, what is it, Psyche?
It's a bit vague.
I'm afraid I'll need another chance to look into...
Hey, kid.
Huh?
Talking to yourself?
You're right.
It's a good way to fight the boredom in here.
From Omega, I suppose.
Who are you?
Captain Jergal of Origa.
Omega's ally only these days.
you're lucky if you know who your real allies are why are you in here you tell me as a rule a
little smuggling here and there nobody paid any attention no questions only this time they sent
fighter ships after me and i got the message land or else so i didn't argue it's three months now
that we're here rotting in ourselves and who can say how long we're gonna stay here that's it captain
they say that various serious events will soon take place it could explain why they had to arrest
you hang on you got a very interesting idea there they want total secrecy concerning what's going on
here look they're ahead i'll tell you i was more than a little surprised at all the action down
there a train let's go in closer and take a look i tailed it out a ship could have taken a few hits
and stayed in one piece but i wasn't worried what could they do nothing in a little while i'd shoot
out of there anyway it was three months ago is your ship still at the spaceport and in good shape
perfect shape at least that's how it was we don't know what they did with ours well it's a risk we
had to take captain i'll make a deal with you okay we'll help you to escape and you'll fly us off the
planet what do you say is it a deal oh that's the best one yeah you say you'll get us out
i'm used to taking risks we all do sure anything you like i'll take you anywhere you like but
didn't you know that no one has ever got away alive from a high security prison in cassiopia
Guard! I would like you to unlock the cell.
Do it now.
Thank you, Bull.
Find them.
Help me to find my cell, if you please.
C has been off.
Okay, Metro. Cells in section C first.
Local alarm.
Binary. Take hours to explain it to you. I suggest we go first.
A moment.
It's a chance.
Wait, we haven't a chance.
It is well constructed, and there's a trick or two I'd like to show those hotshots.
Okay, fellas. We die together.
And it gained us a little time.
Watch this.
The boundary of Cassiopeia is not fast and as will they fast.
Look at the radar.
Coming back.
Without help, we're lost.
This is Lieutenant Piero, Omega Intergalactic Patrol.
Do you read me?
This is the cruiser Hummingbird.
He's still there.
He didn't get away.
We didn't think of him.
About time somebody thought of me.
About Metro.
Where are you calling from?
Cassiopeia?
First night, I'm just above your head.
It's nice out here.
Glorious scenery.
There's one advantage to being a robot.
For instance, now I've no need to breathe.